um
I haven't I haven't even grown up with
my daddy and I still do
um
like from visual experience it's less
hassle it's got less layers it's
clear-cut it's yeah less time consuming
and obviously I generally feel like men
are protective to me if obviously the
ones I'm attracted to do and I feel safe
around if I feel safe around you then
I'm gonna trust you're gonna make a
protective decision make like you're
gonna make a decision that's going to
protect both of us not saying I won't
but I'm gonna protect you in the uh
subconscious I'm gonna protect your
emotions I'm gonna protect how you may
not be seeing things looking at things
but on the physical maybe go get it is
there any other girls that feel like her
on a panel can you just put your hands
up
oh sorry and can I just ask can I just
ask you like can I ask you a bit so why
do you feel like that what trusting men
yeah why do you trust him in the man's
leadership
um I think men are more logical women
there's a lot of problems that come
along with their decision-making like
emotion and
I don't know I just I've always looked
up to men more than women generally
speaking because I feel like the
decisions they make pay off better
quicker decision making and I don't know
I just think the results are the results
show off much better than the decisions
that women make push
um I would say that my brain this is on
topic just to start this is on top here
but I'm going to start it sounding a bit
off topic my brain's a bit more um
animated so I see the way men think as a
waffle
you know like squares
women think like spaghetti okay I'm with
you yeah so I'm hungry yeah you get it a
bit of food before but um you know like
when you tell a man something they will
execute it Box by box a female will
maybe because we're on the spaghetti
route we've probably gone down like
we've done Snakes and Ladders on you but
you've just done ladder did you get my
plates women we tend to add a bit more
sauce to the mixture but men keep it in
line so if I had money not to say I
couldn't spend it wisely but you might
already have something in place because
you've been doing a box box I've done it
scribble here scribble there I've done
it all over the place yeah you've done
it look babe
[Music]
but in a different manner you've
probably put into a better perspective
for me so I would give my trust more to
a man not to say that I don't trust
myself but I would rely or be open to
rely on his judgment based on the fact
that I I you know believe that he's got
this on board like he's with it right
here what about you why do you trust the
mental leadership
um I just think men are better at
certain things in general
um like I'll give you an example I want
a tan so it's a pretty big sample size
it's just like kids and most of my
brothers are engineers and like most of
um me and my sisters
um actually most of my sisters don't
have jobs yet but they won't be
Engineers like I just know them
um but
I don't know I just think like with
money like especially with money um I
think just men tend to make better
decisions and the data supports it so
like women make 70 to 80 percent of
consumer buying decisions and like we
have more debt even though we make less
money and so to me that's just says like
women as a whole we make impulsive
emotional decisions in general and
there's some women that can kind of turn
that off but I don't think it's like
natural to us and that's why like they
most ad campaigns are targeted towards
women um so I think it's like a mixture
of just like data I've seen an anecdotal
experience where like male coaches I
have had overall you know there's the
one creepy one but oh one not 90
but overall have just been like better I
don't have to deal with like the drama
of you know the female coaches would
almost get involved in the team drama
and the males would just I don't know I
just think men are better at certain
things so is it like because you think
for men it's there they find it easier
to separate like emotions yeah and I can
see it in my because I one thing um I
talk about is I Outsource decision
making sort of like I have a manager um
you might have saw him use in the back
and like even my dad like those are the
two people I talk to about decisions
um and I honestly like trust them with
it because it's it's like okay if you
have to fire someone in a business a
woman's gonna typically typically be
more emotional oh I don't like their
family I don't want to do it I don't
want to fire them like but a man is just
gonna be like he's not doing the job
he's got to go and and I had to have
like that conversation with my dad at
one point he's like you should have been
done this already and it's kind of like
like that I don't know I just think men
can like make decisions quicker where
like women will drag it out how much men
would call that woman that can make the
decision real fast
attractive and they wouldn't I I because
yeah no I I agree with you being that
woman imagine being that number of women
that men are not gonna even look at them
it's not good it's not really because of
the decision making it's because of like
the traits that are generally associated
with it so like like men want to come
home and they just want to feel like
they're at peace like they've been
arguing with people all day like they've
been battling all day they just want to
come home and they want to they want to
have a woman that just makes them feel
good and be nice to them but like those
women tend to be disagreeable they tend
to want to argue and they tend to want
to disagree in any decision he has to
make like she's gonna fight you on it
like the woman that wants to make
decisions like they're not quick to let
their men make decisions and like men
want to be with a woman that feels like
like she trusts him so
um I said like for for us men when you
trust on the man's leadership it's the
ultimate
um
for us we feel like it's the ultimate or
we think it's the ultimate um showing of
love and submission and a lot of times
when people hear submission so
they want me to do that yesterday sorry
yeah so they want me to use Cooperative
because submission tends to rub people
up the wrong way but I'm gonna use
submission by Cooperative because when
you submit to a man it doesn't mean that
it makes you it means you as a woman it
doesn't mean that you can ask you a
random question because this is based on
what you're saying about okay I was
asked yesterday randomly someone's like
I don't think you'll be submissive like
how you're saying even if all women will
submit someone said to me they don't
think I'll be submissive and I was like
why is that because I proved questions
and I was like you just I just didn't
feel like if I wake up in the morning
you'd make me breakfast where have you
got this analogy so you looking at me on
that question yeah
it's not it's not that you don't it's
not I don't know what a breakfast cooker
looks like in the morning
maybe I would like that and I don't you
don't know that the happy person that
would do that and I'm like where's this
coming would you I I think I don't know
you personally but sometimes like like
girls that give off like the 50 50
mindset where it's like well why don't
you cook me breakfast or like they feel
like it should be 50 50 like I don't
know maybe you said something that when
I came off as like 50 50
how have I experienced you on this
platform today like I obviously you're
opinionated and you're not you're not
scared to to depart your business it's
fine on a platform you shoot you should
do that but like what Pearl said man we
just really want peace like you can be
the most intelligent woman I know you're
intelligent I know you could listen you
could be the top debate or you could be
doing but when I just come home I beg
you just oh wow I'll give you this when
you come home it wouldn't be this
actually no no but what I'm trying to
say to you is is we don't know we just
take you for how it is so we say right
if she if I experience in a setting like
this then What's it gonna be like in a
relationship setting what's it give me
like we don't know what it is but the
bit that would attract me to you to
maybe get your number whatever you would
miss past that that'd be your loss I
know I know but yeah
but what's my loss what's your loss it's
all about whatever's not you're not
trying to say to you but it could be
avoided by you know I'm like oh you know
what I wanted this platform and you know
she was a little bit but actually like
the energy like it's something I have to
like because I I debate for a living
yeah but like it's something I have to
kind of like turn off sometimes with the
guys where I'm like oh I know you're
wrong but I just need to like like
because men don't want to do that they
just want you to shut up and be silent
but so it's like I think there's nothing
there's nothing wrong with telling
someone when they're wrong whether
they're man or woman but but in in this
scenario you know if you're gonna tell a
man that they're wrong it's not about
telling them they're wrong that's that's
fine it's just it's it doesn't need to
be done with like the you know the
attitude
even even if you're smart like you're
not you know what sometimes the power in
a woman is black you know what I'm
smarter than him but I just let him have
that and you're just laughing with your
friends
I just feel like guys like like if he
says something that's not statistically
accurate like he doesn't really want me
to like come in and give you all this
stuff as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible